[Musique]
on est bien loin des chants de noëls
d'antan des louanges tropicalisé par
loulou boislaville est allé dans le
fameux livre vert
[Musique]
les ritournelles prennent de plus en
plus des espaces dans les textes les
mélodies affluent sur des rythmes en
tout genre il arrive même que les chants
de noël se transforme en support
s'attirer
ça ne serait pas arrivé si j'avais beau
jeu
sacrilège disent les puristes au marché
du lamentin on crie au scandale ici on
milite pour un retour aux chants
traditionnels
pour mettre des fonds de la chaussée
l'opération tout changer du traditionnel
sapin en cours
[Musique]
les garants de la tradition sont
malheureusement voie de disparition le
dernier disciple de loulou fustige le
goûter spectacle tonique aux cantiques
de noël
les choses ont changé et évolué je ne
sais pas si on peut dire dans le bon
sens ou de la mauvais sens mais elles
ont évolué parce que c'est le cadet des
cours qu'il faut des spectacles de noël
voir effet dû chanter ça fait chanter
déjà la fois des spectacles arts édition
50 sauf ça c'est aussi un podium qui
plus est comme une fête patronale et les
gens viennent avec ou sympathique sans
lumière et ils pourront faire par
exemple les ritournelles pop et nos
combats chatté noël de la page 3
cette évolution n'est-elle pas le reflet
d'une société qui bouge qui évolue avec
son temps au gré des influences ces
instants autrefois d'intimité parfois
des recueils ne sont ils tout simplement
pas devenu aujourd'hui à l'image du pays
martinique
à
[Musique]